the polls have now closed in a regional
election in the Indian state of Delhi
the Assembly vote is seen as a test for
the ruling at BJP following weeks of
often violent protests both in the
capital and nationwide against the new
citizenship law
dozens of Indians were killed and
thousands detained demonstrating against
the law regarded by many as anti-muslim
our India correspondent Elizabeth
puranam has more from the capital New
Delhi polls opened at 8 a.m. here in
Delhi
two-time Chief Minister over the
Kejriwal and has armed army or common
man party are expected to be reelected
by the country's two main political
parties the Bharatiya janta party of
Prime Minister Narendra Modi and the
Congress party have been campaigning
extensively Prime Minister Modi urged
voters to come out in large numbers the
election was taking place after the
biggest protest against Prime Minister
Modi and his BJP government since they
were first elected six years ago that's
after they pass the citizenship
amendment act in December the protests
against the law have been a key election
issue for the BJP they've been very
critical of protesters in fact two of
BJP politicians were banned from
campaigning after one life and
protesters - rapists and murderers and
said they wanted to turn India into a
Muslim country and another said
protesters should be shot and just days
after they made those remarks there were
three shooting incidents against
protesters a Eugeni in one week now
Chief Minister Arvind Kejriwal has
campaigned on his usual platforms of
development of education of healthcare
that has resonated with voters in the
past has common man party won a historic
67 out of 70 seats in the last election
in 2015 the election results on February
11th are going to be watched very
closely will be a key in the
of whether the BJP recent politics and
campaign have worked